on fait le point avec année guérard et
lé chef de l'exploitation chez transat
confort madame guérard histoire on
s'imagine que c'est un soulagement sur
le décollage pour transat n'est ce pas
oui ça a été une longue période pour
nous d'attentes donc aujourd'hui à
l'heure où on se parle en fait de
londres déjà des vols qui commence à
décoller sur les différentes
destinations on avait suspendu nos
opérations depuis 1er avril c'est
vraiment on n'avait jamais fait ça
auparavant je pense que j'ai tout à fait
nous mêmes dans l'industrie c'est inédit
donc aujourd'hui pour nous c'est un jour
heureux parce qu'on remet la machine en
marche nos équipages sont prêts les gens
sont ultra-motivés puis comme vous
l'avez dit on offre une vingtaine de
destinations presse allemande ont su
dans l'europe et on est très content
c'est tout de même un vrai décollage
partiel quels marchés font les plus
prometteurs pour vous pour l'été vous
disiez en reportage la plupart des gens
qui voyagent en ce moment sont des gens
qui vont résister famille amis en un
petit peu de clientèle loisirs mais
c'est minime donc les vols qui se
vendent bien c'est soit sur paris vers
les grandes villes françaises comme
marseille lyon nantes et toulouse ou six
qui sont très en demande et toutes les
communautés porte portugaise haïtienne
donc les vols sur port au prince sur
lisbonne également se vende à saigner il
ya d'autres destinations qui sont un
petit peu plus difficile quand on
regarde notamment du côté du royaume-uni
de londres parce que
il ya des pays comme ça qui impose une
quarantaine à l'arrivée au canadien
alors ce qui fait qu'une personne ne
pourrait partir d'ici aller à londres
faire une quarantaine revenir faire une
quarantaine mais la plupart la plupart
des pays sont ouverts sans contrainte
aux canadiens ce qui est pas le cas dans
le de l'autre côté
cela dit on envoyait dans le reportage
des images à l'aéroport il semblait pas
y avoir foule loin de là est-ce que la
réponse est bonne est ce que vous avions
sont pleins
les avions sont pas pleins et on voulait
pas qu'il soit appelé non plus parce
qu'on est en train de tester en même
temps nouvelles mesures sanitaires mais
on est surpris parce qu'on a mimé vous
le disiez aussi c'est on a réduit notre
capacité de 80 % sol était donc les vols
qu'on a en ce moment se vend bien à
l'exception de quelques vols mais ça
demeure toujours une demande qui est
très très très modeste par rapport à tes
histoires et qu'on a connus mais on sait
très bien que les gens ont envie de
voyager les gens nous appellent les on
ad nous appelle mais ils doivent
reprendre confiance
donc c'est à nous aussi dans notre eau
de donner confiance
vous faites quoi pour les ratures et
assurer leur sécurité vous avez mis en
place tout un protocole
oui on a lancé un programme protection
voyageurs en se basant sur les
recommandations des autorités puis en
mettant une couche de plus là pour
transat
donc la première chose c'est qu'on a
développé un programme complet de
mesures sanitaires à tous les points de
contact avec le client donc aux diverses
étapes de son parcours
que ce soit à l'aéroport avec toutes les
questions de santé qui sont posées la
désinfection des bornes et des surfaces
la prise de température
également on a aussi des nouveaux
processus d'embarquement ou rempliront
refaire embarquer les gens de l'arrière
vers l'avant pour qu'il y ait moins je
dirais de contact entre les personnes
ensuite il ya un processus de nettoyage
et de désinfection à bord sur toutes les
surfaces allant chaque vol ayant
profondeur à la fin de chaque journée
donc sondé des nouveaux équipements pour
faire ça également il remet aussi à tous
les clients une fois à bord ou trop de
protection voyageurs qui comprend un mas
des gains du désinfectant et bien sûr là
tout notre personnel tient qu'un kit de
protection également s'assurer que tout
soit conforme bon en espérant que les
voyageurs se sentent rassurés cela dit
j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur les
modifications vous avez annoncé
aujourd'hui pour votre politique de
crédit voyage qu'est ce qui change bien
en fait les crédits voyage on avait mis
jusqu'à présent était valide pour 24
mois et ne pouvait pas être transféré à
un autre individu donc c'est ce qu'on a
assoupli après avoir réfléchi parce que
ça ne rapporte beaucoup de complexité
mais
on s'est dit que c'était la meilleure
chose dans le contexte après réflexion
ou après de la pression des des clients
madame guehrer d'un petit peu des deux
je veux dire il faut prendre en
considération bien sûr douce et si
c'était juste de nous honnêtement on
demande pas mieux qu'à rembourser les
clients
si l'exil jouer fort d'ailleurs il ya
plusieurs transporteurs internationaux
qu'ils l'ont fait pourquoi pas le faire
c'est prendre un bain il faut comprendre
la situation les transports
internationaux les transporteurs
internationaux qui ont commencé à
rembourser les clients qui offrent le
remboursement comme une des options
alors pour la plupart c'est des
transporteurs qui ont reçu une aide
gouvernementale
alors aujourd'hui lorsqu'on regarde
l'industrie canadienne du transport
aérien il n'ya pas d'être gouvernemental
précise ciblées pour sauver les
compagnies aériennes canadiennes
donc premièrement ça nous rend beaucoup
moins compétitif pour une reprise alors
que les compagnies comme air france klm
les uns d'autres compagnies européennes
les compagnies américaines également en
le soutien du gouvernement d'un point de
vue financier ils sont à mesure de
pouvoir offrir un remboursement aux
clients et en plus ils ont tous soutien
financier pour pouvoir redémarrer ce
redémarrage un coup nous on redémarre
mais sait on redémarre à perte c'est
combien par mois mais peu rentable en
terminant madame berra ou les fréquences
cette rentabilité
ça va dépendre de la demande quel et les
gens ne fassent confiance mais on
s'attend à ce que ça revienne
allez allez me reprocher sûrement si on
a bon programme et on a réussi à
convaincre les passagers que c'est
sécuritaire de voyager avec nous on
s'attendrait un retour un meilleur
retour du real id est reproché mon cas
on sera encore rentable avant un an ça
sinon faudra être patient clairement je
voudrais une passion madame gerrans
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là avec
plaisir